he's so fun every time he comes he just
came in and we had
his alcohol in here too and it was so
good yeah it's good and yeah but i
i love you too you both look like you're
from coming from like some really cool
fair like festival always you look like
so put together
and like i'm like oh that's what that's
what people look like sometimes i guess
not me we're doing the earth day episode
so i guess it was tempting to like come
out with like hemp seeds in my
favorites so cool though especially the
companies that you're you're wearing
right now too i think that's so
important
because you look badass and like that's
what a great outfit and
also looking out for the planet my new
jam is trying to figure out how we can
wear the same things over and over again
and make them look different
well simon cow's been doing that for
quite some time
he has been wearing the same black shirt
and jeans
for since i've known him he's not trendy
better he's a real
he cares about the earth more than all
of us yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever